the chief Constable of South Yorkshire
police Lauren poultney traveled to a
neutral location with a colleague
who claims that as a child she was raped
by a police officer in Sheffield
Leona told her story in a sky news
interview broadcast earlier this month
age 13 she was befriended by this woman
Amanda Spencer who was jailed in 2014
for grooming vulnerable teenagers and
then selling them to a gang of child
abusers the owner said one of the men
who abused her was a police officer who
later picked her up in his car she spoke
to the chief constable and then
privately gave details to a
counter-corruption officer women I've
spoken to throughout the year on this
issue don't have an awful lot of
confidence in the police to investigate
these kind of matters
how can someone likely own a be
confident that this is going to be
investigated so if I chair the national
county corruption Advisory Group and one
of our key work streams is sexual
misconduct and sexual offending by
police officers there's a group that's
committed to bringing this into sort of
sharp Focus across the country to
identifying those people who are
perpetrating sexual offenses whilst
police officers and ensuring that they
are rooted out of policing there is no
place in policing For Those who commit
sexual offenses earlier this month a
police inspectorate report found that
senior officers in forces across the UK
had failed for a decade to tackle
predatory officers and needed to improve
their vetting
Leona says she feels she's now being
taken seriously for them to actually
believe and
want to help that's weird
um
us knew us a little bit overwhelming
because
we were the blame for so long
right now there will be little there
will be kids
that has lost afraid scared oh Lord
they'll not see any way out no Escape
Leona says she doesn't want to relive
her abuse but is doing it for those
children out there somewhere who is
still suffering
these situations make you feel like
you're the loneliest person in the world
and you shouldn't
because you're not on your own I promise
you
I promise you
Jason Farrell Sky News